Have you heard of a dragon whose tail releases
a spray of explosive slime?
Or a dragon that hunts with noxious fumes?
Or one that vomits spires of super-heated
glass?
Across various myths and cultures, dragons
have taken on many forms.
But few are more fearsome than the terrors
that lurk within the pages of the Dragonslayer
Codex — a worldbuilding project from the
brilliant imagination of artist Sawyer Lee.
The volume is written as a survival guide
to the world’s most dangerous dragons, explaining
their abilities, behavior, and how to slay
them if necessary.
But be warned: many of these scaly tyrants
will not go down without a fight.
So, for this entry into the archive, we’ll
learn critical things about each species that
can mean the difference between survival and
searing flames.
And as usual, you can support the artist on
Patreon and follow the project using the links
in the description.
Now, let’s dive into the burned pages, and
discover the secrets of the Dragonslayer Codex…
In the open plains, our first species of dragon
paints the land red with their terrible wrath.
The nightmarish Scarlet Lashers are a threat
to anything that enters their domain.
Lasher territory typically encompasses wide
spaces that allow full use of their whip-like
tail — which according to legend, can slice
a bison in half.
As elegant as they are lethal, the agile Lashers
are known to move like malicious dancers.
Their rust-colored eggs are a prized ingredient
in alchemy — and possess an unusual shape
to help them stay in their nest.
And a Lasher’s nest is a grim sight indeed.
During breeding season, Lashers construct
great ground nests composed of branches, bones,
and strewn corpses.
These disturbing corpse-nests aren’t just
to protect eggs, but to show off the Lasher’s
skill to a potential mate.
Throughout the mating period, the scales of
male Lashes will flush a deeper red than usual,
and they scream a dreadful call into the night,
which can be heard for several kilometers.
Beyond mating calls, the multi-chambered airways
within the dragon’s crest amplify sound
to a lethal degree.
As a result, slayers are advised to shield
their ears when pursuing a Scarlet Lasher.
Yet perhaps the most terrifying feature of
the Lasher is their keen intelligence.
A hunting style that involves outsmarting
small prey animals has resulted in an exceedingly
crafty species.
Should you decide to venture into a Scarlet
Lasher’s territory, you must constantly
watch for traps, pitfalls, and other entanglements
of the dragon’s making…
Should you survive these traps and journey
to the dark islands just off the coast, you
would face another fascinating but frightening
species.
One of the only known ‘flightless dragons,’
the Sicklemouth are a lineage infamous for
their sword-like jaws.
They use these jaws to settle territorial
bouts with others of their own kind, and have
even been documented sparring with each other
— seemingly for practice.
Even by human standards, the Sicklemouth is
an extremely adept swordsman.
In combat, slayers report, their attacks resemble
those of trained professionals, not simply
wild beasts.
Many explorers have been caught off guard
while charting these islands, and have met
their end underestimating the Sicklemouth.
These clever beasts enjoy the challenge of
the hunt, so if you wish to shoo one off,
it’s best to make your fighting seem boring.
If you must tangle with a dragon, one weapon
a slayer should always have on hand is a Drakeprier.
A kind of melee multitool, these versatile
devices can catch a dragon off guard if wielded
correctly.
But since mishandling can result in the loss
of a finger, they should only be used by trained
professionals...
When crossing the expansive sands of the Dune
Sea, you and other unlucky travelers might
hear a series of choir-like calls.
These aren’t the sounds of some lost musician,
but are the deceptively melodic cries of Wailing
Bishops.
A dragon subspecies common to desert environments,
Wailing Bishops are famous for their silver
scales, which reflect the harsh sunlight.
These dragons can also vibrate their scales
while in flight, creating a mesmerizing hum
that adds to their chorus of sounds.
Wailing Bishops feed by skimming the sands
of the great Dune Sea, snapping up any buried
subterranean lifeforms they come across.
This ‘sand-skimming’ behavior is one of
the most unique across the dragon family tree.
The Wailing Bishop’s primary food source
is the water-filled burrowing Dune Mole.
These strange forms of life are also highly
sought after by humans who live in this region
as well — as they are a rare source of water
in this parched wasteland.
While skimming for food, Wailing Bishops also
swallow excess sand.
In the dragon’s stomach, the sand becomes
a goopy, molten material that Bishops then
regurgitate — forming spires of black glass
upon impact.
The Bishops use these to create formidable
obsidian nests, which the dragons use as a
safe place to lay their eggs.
But it’s not a place that’s safe for anyone
else…
Upon the stormy shoreline where the sea clashes
with the land, an unusual subspecies has become
a significant threat.
All slayers would be wise to be wary of the
Tasseled Thundermaw, a semi-aquatic dragon
adapted for both the sky and the sea.
Rippling with muscle and deceptively flexible,
the Thundermaw can be found wherever the water
is cold and the waves are high.
The Thundermaw’s tail is the longest of
any dragon class, which continuously writhes
and coils subconsciously.
Yet what is the purpose of a tail with a mind
of its own?
The answer might have to do with the Thundermaw’s
feeding strategy.
Some individuals have been seen “fishing”
with their flexible tails, which lure in fish
with their wriggling movement.
A question remains, however, as to whether
this is their primary hunting method, or just
a curious pastime.
For Thundermaws can also hunt by sending a
short shock to stun their victims, before
lunging in to deliver the final blow.
It’s a powerful secret weapon, made possible
thanks to hidden organs in the head and neck
region.
This attribute mirrors that of electric eels,
strange beasties known to use their electric
fields both to subdue prey, and to locate
them.
It is likely the Thundermaws can use their
fields to locate prey as well, which would
explain how they always know when to strike…
May be best to leave these dragons to the
professional slayers...
When walking amongst the dense trees of the
region known as the Blood Forest, a slayer
should always keep one eye turned upwards.
For the fast and agile Gaping Kilnneck soar
just above the canopy, ready to snatch prey
with their interlocking teeth.
Kilnnecks are light-bodied dragons, easily
identifiable by their slim form, which is
perfect for maneuvering the densely forested
environments where they can be found.
Their beautiful, frilled tail likewise helps
break the silhouette of this dragon against
the foliage in the Blood Forest.
Yet the most notable feature of the Kilnneck
is their sheer firepower.
While Kilnnecks themselves aren’t the largest
species, their fiery breath rivals that of
even the mightiest dragons.
To produce such a massive wall of fire, like
a common serpent, these dragons can unhinge
their jaws and swing them forwards.
Aside from their signature flame barrage,
Kilnnecks are ambush predators that hunt using
their immense speed.
Observant slayers have recorded them flying
low over the countryside, snatching up anything
from the size of a fish… to the size of
a cow.
But even the most dangerous animal’s life
is more than just hunting.
When rearing their young, these dragons take
a break from fire-breathing to carry their
brood in their unhinged jaws.
Juvenile Kilnnecks have a relatively good
chance at making it to adulthood compared
to other dragons — meaning the Blood Forest
is teeming with full grown fire-breathers.
Only the most courageous—or foolhardy—would
venture in.
On nights when the skies are darkest, slayers
who wish to see the sunrise again must be
on their guard.
A secretive and cunning dragon subspecies
prowls in the shadows.
Black Blisterwhips are so dreaded that just
seeing one is considered a bad omen.
Their dark scales help them vanish into the
night sky.
Unlike most dragons, they prefer to feed on
bone marrow, and possess molar-like teeth
to crack open the bones of their prey.
Like bats, Blisterwhips are known to be nocturnal
— only hunting at night, and retreating
to their dark caves when the sun rises.
And the Blisterwhip’s most deadly ability
is something impossible to anticipate.
When a Blisterwhip swings their tail, it secrets
a highly flammable green slime, which the
dragon then ignites — producing a sudden
wall of searing flame.
It’s one of the most extreme attacks of
any dragon.
When a dragon has a slayer on the ropes, a
slayer’s best friend is a Kinghound.
These giant canines are bred to track and
pursue dragons, with their calloused, hairless
bodies far less flammable than an ordinary
dog’s.
Deeply loyal, they’ll bravely protect their
owners against even the most fearsome of foes.
Best to bring one along if you’re perusing
a Blisterwhip.
In the sun-scorched wastes of a region known
as the Gorgelands, heatstroke isn’t the
only danger.
Ruling over the labyrinthian ravines are the
ill-mannered Hellbaskers, creatures just as
unpleasant as the environment they inhabit.
Hellbasker flames are the hottest of any dragon,
and are used to bore the tunnels in which
they nest.
Their eggs are long and thin, able to be hidden
deep inside rocky crags and crevices within
the Hellbasker’s territory.
While the flames of adult Hellbaskers are
hot enough to melt shields and swords in a
flash, the flames of Hellbasker chicks aren’t
nearly as formidable.
The size of small terriers, the sand-toned
wyrmlings are a far cry from the tyrants they
grow into.
When hunting, adult Hellbaskers pursue quarry
into the narrowest of canyons, able to pitch
and control their aerial maneuvers to the
most precise degree.
And such flexibility is necessary when chasing
their preferred prey: Armorheads.
Large, heavily defended herbivores related
to wild boars, Armorhead have well-developed
neck muscles and ever-growing tusks to fend
off Hellbasker attacks.
The Armorhead’s thick skin often bears the
scars of attempted predation, which helps
determine their status within their pack.
Clearly, slayers aren’t the only group who
have had some success fending off dragons...
At the edge of settlements, one species is
known to feast on discarded scraps.
The aggressive Rattle Dreads are scavengers
that seek out small towns for their trash
piles.
Led by the best sense of smell in the known
world, they forage for anything they can fit
into their huge maw.
And anything the Rattle Dread doesn’t eat
they regurgitate out in fiery scattershot,
with this species contributing to the highest
number of dragon attacks to date.
Rattle Dreads are known to incubate their
eggs in their previous prey, making them a
much-reviled species.
Once they hatch from their unwilling hosts,
young Rattle Dreads grow quickly, gaining
almost four times their mass in muscle in
just a few months.
But to reach such sizes requires a tremendous
amount of food.
These hungry beasts aren’t afraid to enter
barns and homes in search of a meal, and are
completely confident around humans.
You’ll be warned they are coming by the
rattling of their mane of hollow spikes — a
sound that signals hungry mouths in the dark.
By the time you hear it, though, it may already
be too late.
Some Rattle Dreads have even been known to
play dead in the hopes a carless human will
approach.
One way or another, these scavengers get their
meal…
Within the mossy woodland, a unique foe turns
the land into a minefield.
The Emerald Bombardier is a relatively small
dragon with a relatively large trick up its
sleeve.
While perched high up in the trees, Bombardiers
build fortified nests of hardened saliva.
Glowing chunks of this ‘Dragonstone’ sometimes
fall to the earth and explode under enough
pressure — a trait that makes Bobardier
saliva a highly sought-after weapon of war.
But Bombardiers don’t give up their saliva
so easily, and defend their forests to the
end.
And there is another curious lifeform in these
temperate forests.
The Inusitherium are large herbivores that
tower over Emerald Bombardiers, and show that
dragons aren’t the only expectational creatures
in this world.
Their unique, modified hooves aid them in
lowering branches, and in defending themselves
from predators.
Their hardy and self-sufficient nature means
that they make highly prized domesticated
animals to the scattered human populations
that dwell here…
Upon the weathered mountains of the coast,
a seldom-seen creature glides upon the thermals.
A rare, solitary species, the Veilwright is
a dragon lineage with highly unusual features.
Their multiple nostrils churn out smoke wherever
they go, suffocating attackers and veiling
themselves in a dark cloud.
Thanks to their smoking camouflage, few Slayers
have ever seen a Veilwright in full.
Likewise, these dragons keep their eggs in
foggy, hidden nests high in the mountains.
When Veilwrights chicks are first born, they
latch on to their parents for warmth, clinging
to their bodies for a period that can last
several months.
Veilwrights feed upon the poisonous vegetation
that flourishes in their native habitat.
And these dragons are capable of isolating
and weaponizing the deadly chemicals within,
fusing it with their smoking shroud.
Different plants have different effects: with
Lone-wart causing temporary amnesia, Deadleaf
causing neural shutdown, and Throat Oak causing
the esophagus to close.
Even if a Veilwright hasn’t recently ingested
poison, their veil of smoke is a powerful
tool for distraction.
Even an experienced slayer might struggle
to tell where a Veilwright is within their
cloud — uncertainty which can often prove
fatal.
Many accomplished slayers have met their untimely
end underestimating species like the Veilwright
— whose size suggests an easy mark, but
whose arsenal of abilities can overpower most
any foe.
It is best to avoid confrontation with these
dragons entirely...
In the frozen wastes of the far north, the
slopes echo with the call of a great behemoth.
One of the heaviest dragon lineages, the Hullbreakers
physique reflects their extreme lifestyle.
They have developed a novel adaptation to
the harsh ice of their habitat: pummeling
it to mist.
With their enormous forelimbs, Hullbreakers
can smash through the sheets of ice that sources
of food swim beneath.
Their eggs are kept warm in pouches beneath
the dragon’s wings, which reduces the risk
of losing them to the surrounding ice.
Once a juvenile hatches, they are dangerous
even in their youth — often towering over
adult slayers.
Juvenile Hullbreakers have been known to inhabit
small, frosty ruins before striking out into
the snowy wilderness.
With their devastating striking ability, an
adult Hullbreaker is not a force to be taken
lightly, as their fists can smash through
more than just the ice.
With such oversize forelimbs, one might assume
the Hullbreaker would be entirely flightless.
Yet despite their weight, Hullbreakers are
capable of gliding short distances, with their
immense punching force making for excellent
launches.
Just as wild and unforgiving as the snows
they tread upon, Hullbreakers have singlehandedly
caused the loss of many an aspiring crew.
With all their incredible power, this is a
species that only the most qualified slayers
should contend with.
In the highest mountains of the known world,
one of the most dangerous species of all rules
over the skies.
An avalanche of muscle and horn, the Great
Kinsbane has unmatched aggression and sheer
strength.
Most stories concerning castle guarding dragons
are inspired by these beasts, who live wherever
they please.
Indeed, no human slayer has ever successfully
managed to defeat one.
The eggs of the Great Kinsbane are as tough
as the beasts themselves, with shells that
resemble balls of iron.
Their hatchlings, likewise, emerge bulky and
well developed — although they need the
help of a parent to break through the iron-like
shell.
Great Kinsbane have been known to sleep for
an entire month while their eggs incubate.
But even a sleeping Kinsbane can still be
a serious threat to anything that creeps too
close.
Only a fool would test their luck around such
dangerous forms of life.
With all that slayers have learned about dragons;
it is easy to feel that humanity should no
longer cower in fear when they fly overhead.
But in the case of the Great Kinsbanes, a
little cowering is probably a good idea…
The Dragonslayer Codex is a survival guide
to a land torn between humans and dragons.
Yet perhaps things won’t always be this
way.
Within the world of the codex, some slayers
are making an effort to better coexist with
these creatures — and perhaps one day form
alliances with the incredible beasts.
Sawyer Lee hopes to publish the codex as a
physical book in the future, and if that’s
something you’re interested in, remember
you can follow and support the project using
the links in the description.
A follow up volume, the Drakonry, is also
planned that will explore the possibility
of things like Dragon riding — so stay tuned!
And as always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious.
See you in the next video.